he was every year we would run an
exercise a tabletop exercise where we
rehearsed the build of the fabric uh
routinely but we also ran a tabletop
exercise to go through all those sorts
of contingencies what would happen if it
was raining and what would happen if
there was a fire somewhere or a security
incident so yes there are lots of
variations of the plan to cope with with
all those sorts of contingencies but can
I just make one point which I think is
relevant to what you were saying with
your panel earlier and that was what the
relevance of all this pageantry is
um of course it shows us all fits very
glitzy it's a great advertising for the
UK more tourists are likely to come to
London and so on and so on but
the the international broadcasters have
been asking me what's the point of the
pageantry and uh and I think some people
in this country wonder that as well and
I think the one of the major points of
the pageantry is that
rather like Westminster Hall that was
built a thousand years ago our monarchy
has been going for a thousand years and
these Traditions Customs uniforms uh
archaic ways of doing things are part of
our heritage and uh I think there are
two key things that that they
demonstrate one is they are part of the
fibers
that make up the fabric of the nation
that we are the national identity that
we have
and I think the second thing is that it
reminds us of the heritage of our very
stable democracy compared to some of the
regimes as head of states in other
countries even around Europe well some
of the regimes that were in the in the
Abbey today
um thank you very much indeed Lieutenant
General David Lee congratulations on
your role in helping it all go so
swimming I know every black Rob would
have put a lot of backbone into this and
it was certainly it was magnificent
success so thank you very much
Ken just coming back do you want to talk
to you just personally you know you've
been around the royal family for a very
long time uh obviously protecting them
and they're very well protected today
when you look at William Harry who
you've known since they were tiny boys
and they're in the procession
but there's no real contact between them
that we've seen even in the 10 days very
light contact no apparent talking it
seems to be a temporary truce to put
their grandmother first but underneath
it this Rift that continues to rage what
do you make of that and what do you
think Charles could possibly do to try
and get through all this
right you know there is clearly a rift
and but this is very much ceremonial
there on duty and and that's a very
important word for those of the raw
family because it's all about a sense of
Duty I mean Harry had no choice he had
to be there you know the fact that that
he was in uniform today was on the
assistance of his father but you know
the the the ER initial was removed from
I thought that was churlish but well if
you're going to let prince Andrew have
ER on his shoulder then why wouldn't you
let Harry
I don't disagree with you I I I I do
think it was a bit chillish because you
know this is a a state event and and
let's be honest that Harry himself is
the the only member of the royal family
recently there's actually fought a
campaign in Afghanistan and and he he
alone should I think been allowed to do
that with with all the incidents it
seemed a bit chilly I mean I've got no
truck for Harry's behavior in the recent
years but this was his grandmother he
did serve his country with great Valor
two tours of Afghanistan
um and we've already had the about the
uniform to start with what Andrew was
given dispensation to wear his and then
eventually Harry was led away is to then
remove the ER and have it centered
without the initials of his own
grandmother I just thought don't be
churlish and actually don't fuel his own
in innate sense of victimhood right just
don't give him an excuse to moan again
but I I'm not I don't know exactly what
the protocol on that was but what what
you know what's clearly to me I mean
right I do know is that you know the
prince of was when Winnie had when he
was told that you know some five years
ago to take on greater responsibility
given the state of the the health of the
Duke of Edinburgh then and the queen
herself you know he was already planning
his kingship and and once very much it
wanted that point very much Harry and
William to be part of that that move
towards a new monarchy I actually think
that he still believes in that please
how how he can actually bring that about
oh I don't know I don't think anybody no
it's it's I mean it'll be fascinating
what happens I mean if Harry brings this
book out and its spray guns are all
family all over again as he did with the
Oprah interview I mean all hell's going
to break loose and I think it would be
very disloyal towards his father who
from what I'm told is completely bemused
about why his son has turned Rogue on
him well listen we had this discussion a
few days ago and I and I sort of I
hesitated on the decision I said there
should be a reflection and I I himself
had a reflection appears I I do think
that now given all that's happened in
the last 10 days I think Harry really
should be considered about actually sort
of ending this story and saying look
this book isn't the right idea yeah
because what's it going to do it's going
to cause a great deal of hurt a great
deal of doubt I just think they should
stop talking about the Royals they've
left the country they've left Royal Duty
they apparently wanted freedom and
privacy and yet all they do is
constantly give interviews or public
statements or podcasts or books whatever
it may be in which they trash their
family in the monarchy and at some point
you've got to think why are you doing
this how are you getting happiness or
Freedom yeah well I continue to do it I
mean you know they made the Queen's life
more difficult in her last two years you
know Philippa died and she was in ill
health she must have been hating what
they were doing uh to the to the brand
of the royal family so I just don't get
what they think their end game is other
than enriching themselves but at what
cost of their happiness well I think a
lot of people share your view peers and
I'm actually moving that way what the
one thing that Harry and Megan lack is a
good advisor it's somewhere to sort of
really well they've got American you
know Los Angeles Public Assistance but
that's not good enough no because you
know they're at in it for their own ends
yeah I mean but it needs an advisor
someone with with a real knowledge and
understanding of what the king himself
the real shame of it is if they had just
carried on in the same vein they did up
to their wedding well they were very
popular in this country and they
represented a very different more
diverse couple in the royal family and
they were getting great credit and
praise for that if they carried on just
being as they were then I think they'd
have been very popular and quite beloved
members of the family and could now be
real weapons for King Charles to take
the monarchy forward and with a slightly
more youthful and diverse way as it is
they're sort of running this rival royal
family over in California and it's
causing constant friction anyway we'll
see how that all washes up okay great to
see I often think about you with these
things because you were around them all
when they're all kids and I think that
you know and I no Diana would have hated
the fact the boys aren't talking she
would have been I think really
distraught by it yeah but I mean I sort
of have fond memories of working at that
time and you know I I I'm coming more
around your view on this peers but but I
do think that that that Harry is happy
with the situation now I do think now
particularly because he's been here and
I think he realizes that this is where
he should be and I I know deep down that
his father wants him to be part of this
new movement in this new model
it's a two-way street
um well King Charles uh III and other
members are all family are in St
George's Chapel in Windsor for a private
family service right now details of a
service had not been disclosed with
Buckingham Palace calling it a deeply
personal family occasion what we do know
is that the queen will be buried with
Prince Philip next to his coffin and I
think that's one Ray of uh of happiness
for all of us that they've been reunited
on this otherwise very sad day but after
the state funeral at Westminster rapid
thousands Lima Street to see a
Manchester's very final Journey Tucson
George's Chapel in Windsor two of her
beloved corgis were there to greet her
and a more intimate Gathering are
weighted inside the chapel that she knew
from childhood the crown Jeweler removed
the instrument State the Imperial State
Crown the orb and scepter from the
coffin before they were placed on the
altar symbolizing very poignantly the
end of the Queen's Reign and for the
first time ever the breaking of the wand
was televised a ritual mark on the end
of the Lord Chamberlain's service to a
monarch the Queen's coffin was then
lowered into the Royal Vault alongside
the coffins of 25 previous Royals and
right now the lake Queen is being laid
to rest as I said beside her late
husband the Duke of Edinburgh after a
life lived and mourned in public this
moment and it feels right will belong
only to her closest Family
[Music]
all right
foreign
was a stunning day wasn't it with so
many extraordinary moments and visuals
of this country really at its very best
there's a live shot we just took a few
minutes ago of Westminster Bridge
tonight looking absolutely magnificent
the bridge of course that leads into
Parliament and of course to Buckingham
Palace
uh what a site that is what a site the
whole capital city has been today and
here's Windsor Castle tonight uh
Darkness has of course Fallen but you
can see there the flickering uh light
and flag
an amazing
final resting place for most of the the
queen of course well joining me now from
Windsor is Jeremy Kyle my talk TV
colleague who's been in Windsor all day
Jeremy what's it been like done it I
mean I was at Buckingham Palace where
there were huge crowds uh all day long
and there was a mixture of emotions I
would say very quiet respectful for
large periods breaking into Applause at
certain points
um some tears uh some laughter I mean it
was a sort of range of emotions really
was it like that at Windsor
exactly appears to be fair it was
extraordinary um I've I mean I live in
Windsor as you know and I I've never
seen so many people and I said I said
earlier the queen transcended I think
almost every different part of our
population and people teamed into
Windsor today mate I would say 250
000 minimum and when that hearse came
down the long walk there was this
incredible hush there was like this sort
of Serenity this sort of acceptance that
this was the final goodbye and she was
passing uh on and King Charles would
would be exceeding to the throne etc etc
but you're right a sort of way of
emotions people crying people cheering
clapping as she went past people
throwing flowers but it felt very it's
very proud to be part of it mate to be
honest it was very emotional but it was
also very very historical you know a
moment that you'll go I was there I saw
her 70 years on the throne yeah I felt
that very strongly at Buckingham Palace
while we've been talking the Princeton
Princess of Wales William and Kate have
tweeted goodbye to a queen a mother a
grandmother and a great grandmother
which I think says it all from the
family point of view is that she was our
Queen she was their queen of course too
but essentially for them this was the
matriarch of their family
absolutely the sort of fulcrum by which
it all you know succeeded and of course
no doubt you and I you know are cut from
the same cloth there will be people who
say well the monarchy survive of course
it will survive when you look at who
came today when you look at how the
world four billion people watched us do
what we do best in the most incredible
way of course we'll never see the like
of a lady I mean 70 years on the throne
somebody said to me the day peers that
everybody under 70 whatever has never
known anything else it will be a change
and King Charles will not Reign for as
long as her by any stretch of the
imagination and the monarchy will yes be
slimmed down and we've heard about all
the problems but for me today is about
remembering this incredible woman who
what at 24 25 said however long I've got
I will serve you the British people and
she did that in the most incredible way
just what two days before she passed
there she was accepting Liz trust saying
you know make a new government and she
was about selfless service and I think
the we as a country could learn so much
and actually also I was thinking today
you know with all that's going on in the
world in our world the United Kingdom
why is it that we can come together so
brilliantly at these times why can't we
bottle that peers and use that going
forward because that would have been I
think exactly what she'd have wanted I
completely agree and it is a real
problem that we're becoming ever more
divided as a country it's not just a
problem here it's the same in America I
think toxic tribalism on social media
has made people angry it's made people
constantly confrontational I think that
it's it's a real problem facts don't
seem to matter anymore people just take
a position with a tribe A side and then
they scream at each other morning noon
and night and you know there's a real
moment of unity today but in a way
probably because the queen actually was
completely non-partisan we never knew
what she thought about any big issue so
she never instantly polarized people and
she'd come out and said actually I think
brings it's a bad idea half the country
would have held to be news that are on
Twitter that's where we've got to and
it's it's a completely ridiculous State
of Affairs
um you know there were another part of
today
um Jeremy I thought was great with the
Armed Forces just in all their
magnificent Splendor and I was on air
for Fox and America and I said you know
you've got to remember these are not
just ceremonial
people they're not just doing this to
show off their uniform these are our
fighting forces they're very elite from
the Royal Marines to the gurkhas to the
RAF to the Royal Navy and actually I got
a tweet a wonderful tweet in the middle
of it from a woman called Lisa Moyer who
said my son is part of the gun Carriage
crew he's directly behind the coffin
second in on our right we are
unbelievably proud parents and I
responded to saying so you should be
he's done the nation proud and I was
delighted to see just she was bombarded
with messages of gratitude from the
public and I think there must be so many
different stories of these Armed Forces
today from The Young Sailors by the gun
Carriage to the most experienced people
in the in the Queen's guards you know
the the Grenadier Gardens the coal
stream guards
um all of them to a man and woman were
just absolutely perfect both in the way
that they I mean amazing and the way
they conducted themselves
I think that's right and and actually uh
we've got a we've done an interview for
you later a a lady a squadron leader in
the RAF is 31 years service
um she'd been to the Falkland she'd been
to Afghanistan and she I interviewed her
she was here with a mother who had just
recovered and her two kids and the pride
she said I I've come here today for the
boss it wasn't a job it was an honor and
a privilege and she was so humble and
every one of those 31 days I did for her
and you're right there will be Stories
the length and breadth of this country
and I go back to what I said why can't
we come together as we did today because
old and young where I've been today
peers from 14 and 15 year olds to to 80
and 90 year olds everybody of the same
opinion that this incredible woman
incredible woman gave us all so much and
maybe in her memory actually what we can
give her back is to be as we both said
just to try and get on with our lives
and get I mean we've all heard about the
Duke of York and Harry and that lemon
woman and all that but but actually what
happened today was she transcend did all
those arguments she transcended every
single part of divisiveness we have in
this country and that's why everybody
came together and if we could bottle
that it would be amazing yeah I
completely agree well said Jeremy good
to talk to you
thanks mate
the Majesty took place inside the
historic Westminster Abbey world leaders
World royalty and every living British
prime minister looked on as well as an
estimated audience of billions on
television worldwide well quite a moment
for my next guest Ian greenshields
moderated the general assembly of the
Church of Scotland who read a prayer in
the service
let us give thanks to God for Queen
Elizabeth's long life and reign
recalling with gratitudes
our Gifts of wisdom
diligence
and service
oh God
from whom cometh everything that is
upright and true
accept our thanks
for the gifts of heart and mind
that thou did bestow upon thy daughter
Elizabeth
and which she showed forth Among Us
in her words
and deeds
I'd like to say that the right Reverend
Dr Ian greenshields is with me now along
with former newspaper editor Emily
Sheffield talk TV presenter Richard Tice
thank you so much for coming to the show
tonight uh what a day you must have had
I mean it was extraordinary enough for
us to watch it but to be actually
participating in the historic occasion
of this Queen's funeral must have been
even for you who've done a lot of stuff
quite an amazing moment yes I think it
was I mean I think it was a culmination
of so many historic moments beginning
with the Queen's death in Scotland and
the services and jails and now the
service in Westminster and of course the
further service that followed that it
just was that very profound sense of
history that was there in the making in
that moment and you spent the last
weekend with a Majesty up in Scotland
and you did a remarkable time with her
yeah not knowing of course it would be
the last time you'd see her
to go from that to reading at her
funeral I mean that's an extraordinary
two weeks you've had in your life I know
and there was no sense in which you
would have said that she was frail she
was 96 but there was no sense that you
would have thought that this was
somebody who was imminently going to die
quite the opposite she was very engaged
very articulate memory was great what
did you talk about if you don't mind me
asking presumably you can now say
because we just sadly no longer here but
I mean what what were the conversations
like because they were some of the last
conversations she ever had with anybody
that was something that she she spoke of
more than once and talked about her
mother her father being there her being
there the the joy that it brought her as
a place the peace that it brought her as
a place as well that was something she
spoke about she spoke about
um the church that I belonged to that's
one of the reasons that that I was there
and that she valued uh as well you know
she was quite a character she she knew
her stuff that was one of the things
that was quite remarkable about her I
interviewed actually the former prime
minister of Canada Stephen Harper today
and he was saying the thing about
meeting the queen he met her a few times
got to know quite well was it because
she'd met almost every interesting
person who's ever lived in the last 70
years including every world leader every
scientist every expert everyone she had
extraordinary wisdom and knowledge which
she just amassed over time where she
basically knew a lot about a lot
yes I mean she I asked her who the most
interesting person was that she she'd
met and she'd just answered that
question really really smart well yeah
yeah okay
I said what a favorite him was she
refused
even to the end she wouldn't give
controversial opinion that's right
that's right which was a great side to
him I mean I was quite interesting to
read uh one of Nelson Mandela's
relatives because we're trying to think
of other world events in my lifetime
certainly which could be even close to
this one would have been Mandela's
funeral no question at the funeral of
John Paul the Pope the second and was
huge Kennedy's uh funeral after he was
assassinated and so on I don't think any
of them came close to what we saw today
um but her relationship with Mandela was
quite interesting because apparently his
family always used to tease him because
whenever he spoke to the queen he called
her Elizabeth and they say you cannot
call the Queen Elizabeth and he would
reply well why not she calls me Nelson
they found a commonality together which
she was so good at that she would never
have taken offense at him calling her
Elizabeth she'd totally understand that
he didn't mean that in any derogatory
way and it was obviously great warmth
between them when you were having these
last conversations I don't want to labor
the point because I'd imagine it's also
probably quite painful memories to give
him what happened after but given you in
this sort of moment of History did she
look back at all and reflect on her life
on her reign
she spoke about faith
yeah but then she would do that to
somebody who's who's a minister I
suppose but it was hugely important to
her and it was it was and she spoke
about having no regrets about
the face that she had she spoke about
how important it was to her some of the
unique characters that she'd met as well
Billy Graham being one of them who she
asked to me I think yes her request yeah
she
she had a
do you have a sense that maybe something
was going to happen
it was looking back do you think maybe
she did well some you know how sometimes
subconsciously yes when you look back
somebody has said something to you and
uh and then you think I wonder why they
said that because it it materialized my
own mother did that in the night before
she died really she was just talking
about death and what happened when you
die and and I wonder whether there was
something of that the queen was the
queen dying at all or death or
no she didn't but she was she was
prepared you could tell you could tell
that very clearly and her faith I guess
consequentially would have been that
much more important in that moment of
realizing that her life might be coming
to an end because it would be then the
next stage of of her life and her faith
yes I gave her a gift before I left and
I had crosses made by folks in glenokyl
prison and and I I said to her what what
can you give to the person who has
everything
and she could have smiled at me then and
I presented with a cross and explained
it to her and she very graciously took
it from me and and then just wished me
the best all the best and uh left the
room and then that was the last time
when you stood up to speak today did you
feel that the weight of history on your
shoulders because four billion people
apparently may have been watching yeah I
didn't try to think of it that too much
in Edinburgh that was the case when I
was preaching in Edinburgh and took the
sermon there and
I felt less so here I felt I was part of
something bigger in that sense did the
new king speak to you afterwards
against him everything was moving on so
fast I mean I don't know about you I
found this completely fascinating
absolutely fascinating and the fact that
she said that Balmoral was a her place
of Peace that's true I think is is
really interesting I think it's
interesting maybe I only knew that from
the crown but I feel like that um
Balmoral that Scotland I mean there's
the I see it may have been the film The
Queen with Helen Mirren when she's going
up through the the the the grounds of
Balmoral and she sees the big Stag and
everything and just the beauty the
wildness but also the Privacy that she
had there I think but I think I think
she would have known her own health and
I think it was her final Act of Duty to
the United Kingdom yeah I think I think
she knew that her time was near and that
Scotland Balmoral was was worshiping my
favorite Balmoral story was the the guy
I think he was on sky or something
and he worked with the queen at Balmoral
one of her Pages or valleys or something
and he was asked to reminisce and he
said that he'd been walking with her in
the Balmoral estate and they come across
two American tourists who didn't
recognize the queen
and so they start talking and they say
to the queen oh you know do you have a
holiday home here she would actually I
do yes just over the hill our moral they
said oh well really so you're coming
often I do yeah oh he must have met the
queen and she said well I have them but
he has pointing to the valley or the
page whatever he was or security guy
whatever he was and he chuckled and then
the American couple sees him what's she
like and I think he said something like
I think she could be a bit cantankerous
you know but the queen roaring with
laughter and then they asked the queen
to take a picture of them with this
famous guy who knew the queen who'd met
the queen and then they did do one with
the queen as well all four of them and
the queen apparently chuckled afterwards
and went I just can't wait to hear I
said I wish I could be a fly on the wall
when he gets home those two and they
show their family the holiday snaps oh
well look we met this really famous guy
who met the queen I'm like that is the
queen but that was her sense of humor
yeah that sense of Mischief I mean you
experienced it just gonna resend just
what you hear a moment because I think
I'd like to continue this conversation
I'd like to take a short moment now to
reflect on Her Majesty's extraordinary
life today we mourn but we also
remembered we commemorated a famous
pledge fulfilled
I know that your support will be
unfailingly different
God help me to make good my vows
and God bless all of you who are willing
to share in it we can all share
the Queen's hope
which in life and death inspired her
servant leadership
service in life
hope in death
all who follow the Queen's example and
inspiration of trust and faith in God
can with her say
we will
meet again
well it's 801 welcome to the second hour
of a special program on the day of the
funeral of her majesty Queen Elizabeth
II the greatest Britain it's been a
deeply Moving Day for all of us I think
of grief but also gratitude and
celebration of a life extraordinarily
well LED uh lived it's also been
spectacular hasn't it without any
question a moment of great history a day
I don't think any of us will ever forget
uh well back with my my panel just
didn't want to leave it there just
wanted us to get your final
Recollections really
um or thoughts about the queen as we
move now to a new era a new monarch a
new country in many ways how do you
think history will remember her
I wonder if she realized how much she
was loved yes I think I think she
probably realized she was very much
respected and admired but I wondered how
much she realized she was loved and I
think when you when you listen to
everything that's come across in the
last
10 days or so that's come across very
very strongly from people right across
CNA I mean I I feel grateful Richard
Tice that we had the Platinum Jubilee
because I was told I don't know back in
February March there were serious
concerns about her health and there was
a chance she may not make the Jubilee
and I was told this by somebody who knew
who was hearing this from senior family
and so they were all incredibly relieved
that she did actually hang on long
enough to enjoy what turned out to be a
fantastic celebration of Lorraine in her
lifetime where she was still there to
understand what there was a sense
actually appears that she rallied she
rallied for that extreme ordinary
occasion in the same way I think she
actually rallied in order to bring in
the 15th prime minister I think that we
will always say
she was always there she was the
constant and we now know just how much
she would have admired all over the
world yes I agree
what are your final thoughts about the
queen
oh gosh so many I mean it's hard to
crystallize it I think it's very hard to
crystallize I also think it's gonna be
quite interesting how everybody feels
tomorrow and in the coming days
um because we've had this huge no first
there's the shock then we've had this
nine days people have joined that queue
which became like a pilgrimage which was
sort of quite staggering really I spoke
to a woman on on radio on on Saturday
who was 70 and had done 12 hours and I
said were you tired didn't your feet
hurt and she said no no the spirit just
carried me through I she adored the
queen so much she's from Jamaica and I
think it's going to be it's going to be
quite interesting how this week goes
because there is going to be quite
understandably a moment of sort of dip
do you know what I thought something
particularly maybe for the royal family
and you wonder well they're going to
have I think they have now the faith is
going to his faith yeah he's going to
carry but I think they now have a week
of private morning where they just
disappear now from from sight and they
they have a chance to mourn as a family
I mean I I thought that the queue in
many ways uh it's quite interesting
actually even Americans on American
television today were talking about the
queue and they never know what the word
means they say lying but they've all the
queue has become this world famous thing
this British cue for the British is the
queue of all queue yeah yeah yeah
um but there was a there were several
things about the queue which really
moved me one was just hearing all the
stories from the people being
interviewed all the time that'd be quite
mesmerizing secondly seeing them how
they actually paid the respects I found
that live stream mesmerizing I just used
to watch it for like half an hour every
now and again and you see people either
nodding or muttering thank you or
courtesy whatever it was just so simple
but so respectful and so moving and then
there was the last person in the queue
today who turned out to be a woman who
was in the RAF I'm not quite sure what
she did but I'm sure the papers will
tell us tomorrow
um and she had been twice so she'd gone
through once and then gone straight back
to the back of the queue and queued all
over again and was actually the last
person to come in and I thought well
that doesn't epitomize the Queen's
stoicism determination respect dignity
all those things that the queen
represents then nothing does but don't
you rather hope that in the same way
when we went out and collapsed the NHS
there was a moment of real unity and I
hope and I remember keeping that sort of
inside me for quite a long time
afterwards I still think back I do hope
that we do take something more profound
I totally agree Elementary
and it stays with us in in some way we
don't all just go back where everyone's
being horrible on social media and
everyone's going everything's completely
awful and this country's awful you know
I do think why don't we just ask each
other he wanted to leave us something
well I think Reverend Eric winch has to
end this this part of the of the show I
just think if we all just take a moment
every now and again say what would the
queen do
in this situation what would she say
what would she feel that we won't go far
wrong because her basic gut instinct for
what represented the greatest of British
values actually is what made this
country great and we've deviated way too
far from what she stood for and I by the
way include myself I'm not claiming to
be some virtuous person here I think
I've been watching it going yeah what
can we learn what can we learn about she
is going back a bit actually reset and
go back to those great values thank you
to my pattern what an honor for you and
uh how brilliantly you delivered it and
how extraordinary that you were with the
queen and that last weekend and you must
have just remarkable memories you'll
never you'll never lose ever forget yeah
yeah great to see you thank you very
much and thank you both uh for coming in
I want to get it up to Rupert Bell who's
our talk radio Royal correspondent
Rupert your brother was actually at some
George's Chapel there as part of the
racing community and and Westminster
Abby indeed in fact I know somebody else
who was there
um purely because of the Racing
Connection as well so a lot of racing
people seem to have been involved today
which would have been how the queen
would have wanted it
absolutely it has to be because I know
all those trainers just as you were
talking to the person from the church
that they were talking to her right to
the very end and I know from my own
brother's experience he was talking to
the last week and he always relished his
conversations with the queen about
horses not only the horses that often
ran for him not particularly well for
the queen but he he put on a brave face
and she was very philosophical about it
but she would want to talk about
everything and I know what it it's a
huge privilege for well my family and
for my brother that that he was able to
train for her and he had plenty of
winners he trained the the winner that
was the first horse trained by the uh in
the Queen's colors it was written by
Haley Turner or lady jockey so he had
some wonderful memories and uh I know as
a family we do as well but I think the
important thing was the brain was
absolutely still on the money right to
the very end as we've heard from every
person you know even Liz trust and
that's I think what is sort of Taken
Everyone by surprise that she was still
able to operate yet the suddenness of
what happened when you think peers that
two weeks ago we were announcing a new
prime minister uh and and all that that
entailed and then we fast forwarded
today we've just seen the most
extraordinary outpouring of affection
from this country both in here in London
at Westminster Abbey and then
subsequently at St George's chapel and
all those people in between it's been
the most
extraordinary seismic moment in our
country's history yeah and the the
pallbearers uh the fascinating story
behind them all from the first Battalion
of the Grenadier guards I'm told that
there were a pool of around 30 who've
been basically rehearsing this for quite
some time and that five of them actually
were flown back from Iraq where they've
been in operational duties and these are
obviously acting uh serving soldiers
um what do you know about this Paul
bearers because they've become national
heroes I mean I think that particularly
when they were going up the steps at St
George's Chapel uh carrying this this
huge heavy coffin tremendous pressure on
them
yeah well I'm an ex-grenadier so for me
as an ex Grenadier hugely proud yes I
know the Queen's company is it's still
named it won't be called The King's
company until maybe a week down the line
so those soldiers from the Queen's
company the first Battalion it's now the
only Battalion of the Grenadier guards
but of course they were hugely important
throughout the ceremonial duties today
but those eight soldiers who were
carrying the the coffin I mean five of
them were in Iraq just I don't know 10
days ago and so they've had to rehearse
um within non-stop since then and of
course they're rehearsing with a coffin
that is uh weighs exactly the same and
the young Ensign who was part of that
party uh was only commissioned last
September so from a Grenadier point of
view as I am an ex Grenadier and a
pretty ordinary one at that too it's a
huge sense of Pride that the grenadiers
were at at the heart of it again and
those young men it was the pressure from
them because that is not an easy job
that to actually carry that up those
steps since George's Chapel but also it
actually shows the commitment of the
whole ceremonial aspect of what happened
today there were soldiers service and
and service women coming from all
corners of the globe to take part in
that six thousand of them having to make
sure their part didn't let the bit down
clearly those Guardsmen were in the
front line as it were because they had
some serious you know moments to do into
some George's Chapel Westminster Abbey
and other elements yeah but you've
actually got to give your heart to every
single service men and women because
they were equally as committed to the
cause and as an ex-military man they did
this country proud and they have rightly
achieving all applaudits because it was
magical at every step of the waiting it
was it was completely magnificent uh
thank you very much River Bell
appreciate you joining me uh well
joining me now another military man who
attended the lake Queen's funeral today
the former head of the British army Lord
Bennett Lord Danny great to have you
because I just I can't even imagine what
it was like to be actually at the
funeral we just heard from one of the
speakers there was clearly very moved
what was it like for you uh this was
your commander-in-chief of course for so
long
well Piers of course it was a huge
privilege to be there but you know I
think the thing that was probably
perhaps most significant
um my wife and I were sitting in the
Nave
um we were in the front row of the Nave
but as the leak Queens coffin came by
only two three four feet away from one
one thought ah this is now really
serious this is the this is the end of
her fantastic Reign and it just brought
it home at that particular moment I mean
the service was fantastic the singing
was wonderful the Archbishop spoke well
the lessons were read well but just that
moment of the coffin passing by my wife
Kurt said I bowed I mean that's what we
should do and we just suddenly both said
afterwards oh that's the moment and
houses as it were in front of us this
wonderful 70 rain has ended but now
we've got to look forward to the future
yeah it's it's interesting I I was at
Buckingham Palace all day and I felt
that moment actually when the procession
passed by the palace and I looked behind
me and I saw the hearse coming towards
the end of the procession so it had been
like a good 15-20 minutes of procession
first and then suddenly the the crowd
went very quiet and you saw the hearse
come and then I just watched the hearse
Go Round the Corner of the the big sort
of centerpiece there and come right in
front of the palace I think we're
looking at the images now and I found
that a really moving moment because I
suddenly realized that would be my
personal my last glimpse of the queen
that I would ever have and I found that
very moving actually and I think a lot
of people have been quite surprised how
emotional they felt about all this
um appears I think you're absolutely
right and and those who then
um whether they were present or watching
on television I think when you saw the
the shots of the commercial service
um later on this afternoon and of the
new king and the national anthem was
sung you could just see his eyes welling
up when he realized that yes this was
the moment his beloved mother our
beloved Queen has now gone
and all the responsibilities of the
Kingdom now lie on his shoulders and and
it weighed up I think for all of us at
some point during the day the point
really came home that this wasn't just
theater this wasn't just pageantry this
wasn't just what the UK does best what
Britain does best this was real it was
personal and it was the end of the
second Elizabethan era
but I think we have to be positive uh
and I think of the archbishop's sermon
was absolutely right
um hope is a very important part of
today
um fantastic what a Majesty Queen
Elizabeth II has done the leadership
she's shown the dedication to duty but
we move on and
um we now have a new king uh we've got a
lot of difficulties in the country
energy crisis cost of living crisis new
prime minister we've got to move on
we've got to move forward we've got to
set our sights ahead of ourselves
um but like this sort of ancient
um Plowman who were plowing their
furrows they picked a something in the
just ahead of them and they drove their
horses towards it and that's the
straight line that they took we've got
to take a straight line to better places
and frankly we've got a new king we've
got a new permanent prime minister I'm a
political but we just got to drive this
country forward there's so much
opportunity here let's rejoice in what's
happened in the past but actually fix
our energy and Our Hope on the future
this is a great country it has been a
great country it is a great country and
it will continue to be a great country
we've all got to put our shoulders into
the work absolutely magnificently said
you're not available to join the cabinet
are you any capacity we'll take you as
anything Lord doesn't it
um no I I will if I'm asked
well you know what we could do an awful
lot worse than having someone with your
attitude because we need a bit of
positivity and can do mentality and he
was certainly like that when you ran the
British army it's been a great uh honor
to have you tonight on this very special
occasion given that you were there in
your capacity is one of our finest
soldiers so thank you very much
and and appears thank you are we still
on yes we are yeah
yeah
um one of the lovely things was as all
the royal family came past
um Prince Harry looked in our Direction
and said to my wife hello Peppa just
wonderful that he was back
um I just think Harry is great I just
hope he's got a role to play in our
country in the future I mean it is such
a shame isn't it what's going on there
because there's clearly this huge Rift
with the two brothers there's a rift
between King Charles and his son Harry
and at the moment it seems quite deep
rooted but you do get a sense that Harry
having been immersed back into his
former life in the last 10 days it would
be it would take a Heart of Stone which
I don't think he has to not be
personally affected by in a way that may
make him think am I am I going the right
way with my new life you know constantly
attacking the family the monarchy and so
on is this really helping anybody
well I think the events of the last few
days must have had a significant effect
on Prince Harry and his wife Megan I
don't know what their private thought
processes are what their personal
Ambitions are but what I do know
absolutely is that Harry loves this
country he loved the armed forces his
time in the Army his two deployments to
Afghanistan and I was quite involved in
in both of those were absolutely
formative in his life
um
I wish him all the best I wish Megan all
the best but frankly from my point of
view and I think the British Armed
Forces point of view and a veteran's
point of view we miss Harry we love
Harry
um I don't know how the future is going
to work out but I hope he's got a role
to play in this country in the future
well I hope he was listening to that
because I think coming from you that
will mean a lot to him you know my
brother-in-law actually uh taught him at
soundtirst and and so he spoke very
highly of him said he was an excellent
Soldier as indeed William was very
popular with the the other uh guys and
he he feels very sad about it too
well I persuaded Harry after his first
tour in Afghanistan when he wanted to go
back there I said Harry the only thing
you can do is go back within the
anonymity of a helicopter cockpit and
because a long story short
um he trained to be a helicopter pilot
and he was a good helicopter pilot on
all his weapons course he was the Top
Gun so he's a top Soldier blessing
um such a a great guy and all the
soldiers all the veterans absolutely
worship him he has a significant role to
play in this country somehow he and
Megan have got to find a way to balance
their lives between whatever they want
to do in the states in California but
actually he has a role to play in this
country I know he can't be a part-time
Royal but somehow there's got to be a
role for him because actually we need
him here a lot of people you know what I
think he needs it's very it's very
interesting listening to you talk
because you know him well um and you
know what he feels obviously about the
the military part of his life uh I think
maybe he needs a trip from you maybe get
on a plane to California and go and talk
some sense into him
well um the weather's nice this time of
year um but it but
you're absolutely right well um yeah
maybe well Pierce thank you for the
suggestion if you'd like to send me a
ticket
let's see what happens but um but
actually it's not for me to determine
his life and his family's life he's got
his own issues but all I all I'd say is
that he has played a significant role in
this country I hope he continues to find
a way to play a significant role in this
country within the sort of wider Environ
of the royal family
um but it was just great to see him here
today and um yeah well you know been a
fantastic day a tragic day a sad day but
we have to move forward and King Charles
III God Save the King well done it what
a what a pleasure to have you on the
show thank you very much indeed
thanks peers
fascinating conversation when joining me
now has talked to be presenter Sharon
Osborne the Titan political sketch
writer Quentin let's talk to the
contributor Esther cracker well well I
wasn't expecting that actually uh Sharon
Lord dannick giving that kind of take on
on Harry and actually found it quite
moving because he knows him from his
military time clearly feels very sad
about what's happened but you know try
as part of his positivity
um call trying to see if there's a way
back for him what do you think well I
felt the same when I when I saw him back
in this country and I saw him part of
the royal family again it made me very
sad
I I honestly felt sad that you know this
is his home this is where he belongs the
country loved him so much and I'm sure
they still do the majority and it's just
like
listen nobody knows what goes on in any
family let alone the royal family but
was it so drastic that you had to turn
to California to live a life like a
celebrity yeah quentinlets you're a
brilliant sketch right so I don't even
know where you start with the daylight
today well I think you start with the
fact that it was a state occasion it was
very very stately and it's been a
brilliant success in that respect well
you've moved personally by I was less
moved today than I expected to be until
Westminster until uh Windsor right and
uh I thought the Windsor service perhaps
because I had a bit more cranma to it a
bit more prayer book to it uh and didn't
was not quite so encumbered by stately
Majesty I thought that uh Windsor sort
of got me going a bit more but the
silence in the uh The Abbey service
between the last post and ravalik yeah
that was very powerful and also the
arrival of the coffin uh being pulled by
the naval ratings they came on and the
the music stopped and then they did 15
extra pieces and then halted yeah and as
they marched they were marching on Sand
it made a strange sound it made it sound
a bit like shaking brown sugar in a in a
packet uh very powerful just the sound
of those marching footsteps coming to a
halt that that was one a moment that
stood out some people are seeing this as
a kind of re-energized view to the world
of what Britain does best and therefore
fantastically positive and
forward-looking re-energizing the
monarchy others have said maybe this is
you know the beginning of the end this
is the top it's ever going to be that
this Monarch was as great as we could
ever expect and would actually support
for the monarchy will now slowly start
to fade away what do you think well I
suspect that the poll numbers if you
judge these things by polls which I
don't but by poll ratings then possibly
there will be a little bit of a decline
for a bit because that's inevitable
after such an enormous Peak like this
but what you saw today and what you've
seen the last 10 10 days is the public
saying we are proud of our country we
are proud of our Crown we like things
the way that they are we think this is a
pretty good place to live and
um the the way that that has been
asserted by the public will be absorbed
by politicians and I think perhaps the
political class will be less Holden to
Twitter in the future the problem with
the political class it seems to me in
comparison to say this queen in
particular we never knew what she
thought about anything and the fact of
anything ever got leaked it was a big
history of all time because we just
never heard what what her thoughts were
publicly about anything
didn't mean she didn't have them she
just didn't Express them in public
policy she was not disputation she was
the opposite she was a completely
unifying person she was she was a fount
of Khan right so how so how do
politicians who necessarily take strong
positions on issues which are
necessarily politically polarizing how
can they hope to emulate that kind of
unifying Spirit and the same applies in
America where it's almost impossible now
everything is split down the middle half
the country believes one thing about
most stuff after country
United
States
I think the politicians I mean the
answer to that is the politicians have
to disagree because debate is essential
but it's not so toxic but at the same
time they need to take their their lead
much less from that engine over anchor
that is social media yes and uh I think
that too much of our politics and our
political discourse has been guided by
the ranker the latest pile on from
social media yes these things really
don't matter right that's
that's what people make of today of King
Charles of the monarchy of the future
young person I've actually seen I was
quite surprised I saw a lot of posts on
social media you know obviously bidding
farewell to the queen and actually
saying God Save the King I've actually
seen kind of an uptick in patriotism
that I wasn't expecting right I'm I'm
very curious though how the new prime
minister the relationship she will have
with King Charles because he's obviously
very vocal on things like the Rwanda
policy on on the on green um policy and
all of that I just wonder what some of
their weekly meetings will be because
it's a lot harder to well funny enough
Sharon and I were talking about this on
on Fox this afternoon and I'd slight
issue because Sharon you think he's
going to continue to be outspoken about
issues he cares about because he's been
proven right about something absolutely
um but I I think he has made a decision
that what now he's Monarch he's not
going to do this I really think he's
decided that the only way to be a
popular and long-surviving Monarch
beloved the people like his mother is
just to Simply stop making public
pronouncements about anything that is
remotely political and that would
include things like climate change which
are dear to itself so I just don't think
we're going to see him do that I the one
thing that you did say was absolutely
right that you're never going to please
the mob it's always going to be half of
it that's against you yeah so whatever
opinion you expect me you know I could
go on Twitter and say you know I love
Monday right as a day and within 10
minutes there would be the most
unbelievable part of the people agreeing
with me oh I love it I love Monday night
favorite day of the year and here's why
other people say are you mad if you lost
your mind Monday's the worst day of all
time in other words everything has to
immediately lead to an extreme reaction
everything has to be a toxic debate it
can't be just a bit of fun and that's
the way Twitter in particular social
media has whipped every one of the kind
of permanent lava and I don't I don't
divorce myself from part of this by the
way because I quite often get sucked in
and start you know having a very
consensual figure I'd like to think that
I am a company who expresses firmly
helpful in the water
I'm not taking divisive lectures from
you later one of the most brilliant and
yet pungent writers in the business I
don't think Charles can possibly become
political he can't can it he can't uh
and if he looks at his mother's record I
mean he can't continue to be political
because he has been I continue to do
that and I think he accepted that on the
the first Friday when he said my rule is
now going to change yes and he has to
just pull back from that and be a much
more a tranquil presence and again and
you have to be I do hope I do hope that
I mean his is a face that that naturally
frowns a lot yeah I want my king I'm
proud of King Charles I love smile more
I want him to smile more yeah yeah and
he's he's good at laughter
so far in his Reign he's been mourning
his mother of course and I think that's
easy he's had to tour the country
probably take 100 phone calls a day from
world leaders and stuff he's against
control console his family show us his
King I mean the pressure on the guy is
just unbelievable he took it out on a
pen that's how bad things are yeah and
Sharon what does it say about our
country today do you think what did you
feel when you were watching it were you
getting emotional about a country from
the past that we're slightly losing or
have lost or did you feel in a way it
was a good chance to
three focuses on what makes this country
great
a bit of both yeah really appears a bit
of both I love the way that the whole
country was so United and so together
and there was so much positivity when
you would go into the streets
and yet there are you know certain
groups here that are against royalty but
I think overall I think the Royal
royalty I hope to God is safe here yeah
I mean I think so but I think it would
be
we have a special thing a sporty odd
monarchies left in the world uh of which
12 are European you could take all the
European worlds outside of ours down
Tottenham Court Road
so I think that we are in a very unique
position with our monarchy it is a
unique institution in terms of Fame and
and Global Renault right I think it's in
safe hands I think one of the things I
would say about the younger generation
we're generally excited about William
and Kate and I think what would be
really smart for Charles to do is to
draw on that any sort of engagements
that he has that you know is very near
and dear to his heart he should actually
make sure that William is very present
there because it's kind of like handing
down acquainted with the Commonwealth
you know you're seeing Jacinda ardern
from New Zealand thing it's inevitable
that in her lifetime New Zealand will go
Republic Australia's flirting with it
has a new leader Anthony who is
certainly you know not been full-on
Republican but certainly indicated that
he may go that way if the people wanted
it you'll see some of the Caribbean
countries immediately indicating they
want to have referendums within several
years you know this could if he's not
careful King Charles III you could get a
domino effect if countries suddenly
thinking the Commonwealth as a concept
is over I think that uh the two slightly
different things being conflated there
whether or not Charles's head of state
but whether or not
um countries are part of the
Commonwealth it's two slightly different
things uh I think you have to let those
countries decide for themselves and to
try to resist that or try to impose
um uh our our family as their heads of
state as well we'll be entirely wrong
and counterproductive and so you live
and Let Live
these countries decide how much is the
is the racism allegation which Meghan
Markle the first biracial member of the
royal family of course how much is her
racism claims do you think Esther had an
impact but certainly in in some of the
Caribbean countries I do think it's had
a negative impact but not as much as
people think because I don't think
they're highly respected figures Harry
and Megan I think they come across as
quite wingy and I generally think most
people that talk about the Commonwealth
don't understand it you know there's so
many people in the Commonwealth that
were glued to their TVs today there's so
many people from the Commonwealth
actually are very fond of of the
monarchy and the royal family
um for various reasons I think one thing
I have noticed with sort of the
Republican wave is it's very cyclical in
terms of politics so you have a labor
leader in Australia you have just
another who couldn't be more left-wing
if she tried you know they're always
more on the Republican side of things
but again if you know the elections
swing the other way and you have more
right-leaning governments in they're not
probably probably going to push for by
the way there was a moment today if
you've done your sketch for tomorrow
I've filed because I've never spotted
this but there was no it was an
Australian crew I think it was uh
there's a clip of an Australian that we
all had difficulty today identifying
public figures right A lot of them were
you know heads of states which we just
didn't recognize and so on but you would
have thought they'd only had his trust
by the way have you seen this have you
seen this look at this
who's this no hard to identify maybe uh
minor Royals members of the I can't
identify them at this point
Unfortunately they look like they could
will be local trees it's hard to see
we're looking at the backs of their
heads but I think we are now getting to
the pointy end as they say of the
was I'm just told that was Liz trust the
new prime minister in the distance that
we could see hopping out of that
Australia down to the drigs
I recognized your prime minister Anthony
albanezi immediately an announced him on
American tennis you're too ahead of me
there but did you see the spider when
the when the coffin came in at the west
door and was being carried into the
Abbey there was a spider visible on the
wreath it was a lovely time I had a
lovely moment there was a living
creature on the coffin it was uh yeah I
mean I love moments like that Tony Blair
did you see Tony Blair wearing his
garter he needs a haircut I thought
um I think he was morphing back to his
old rock God days isn't it yeah
what I'm told is I was asking someone
who's you know connected to one of the
prime ministers and all the living Prime
Ministers were there so you've got John
Major you've got Tony Blair Gordon
Browning baby Cameron on Theresa May and
Boris Johnson and although
here's David Cameron today although this
is all that we're going to see you can
check it coming past here so
there's Gordon Brown so you have them
all all these incredibly different
people all of whom have been at long
hairs at various stages of each other
that's the wrong doctor
um but it's it's an interesting thing
that apparently when they all get
together there is there is a shared
common narrative experience of being
prime minister but actually does bring
them together a bit except for major and
Boris is that right they will not talk
really yeah is that right Pete daggers
drawn it always kept as far apart as
possible only you know only plastic
knives when those two is it really yeah
but it must be a strange Club there's
only six of them aren't there left it's
quite a lot we've never had so many uh
how many surviving there's only about
five six U.S presidents I mean these are
small clubs that people are in yeah
they've known the the codes to the
nuclear uh button and that that does
have a sort of um a gelling thing and
also they're in the body of the same
speakers uh um
four American Presidents isn't it it's
how many are still alive Trump Biden
Obama Clinton Carter yes and Carter's
known as late yeah
um Biden I thought should have been
given a more prominent position today I
thought it was a Pity that uh our most
important Ally wasn't perhaps given a
slightly better seat I think he was
there he was down down somewhere near
the dignitaries the top man from Andorra
I think near him but you know that's
that's the Democracy of a church service
and what a a lot of fantastic scene
there was yes the the hymn singing I
thought I thought the chorus
as I wasn't sure about some of the music
in the ABIA the MacMillan piece didn't
really do did you get emotional Sharon
watching Barry did you yeah what was the
moment through the whole day we were
most affected do you think just it was
just one of those days where you really
just wanted to concentrate on watching
every minute of it did you want to talk
to anyone I just wanted to watch it or
because as I said to you earlier it's
history yeah I thought at the moment for
me actually was when
um right at the end when the coffin
started to be lowered oh I found that
very very effective on me because I
thought well that really is the end
that's it that's going to be the last I
see the queen I thought
this is it she's now with her husband
yes well that's the uplifting part of
the day at the very start
yeah it was at the Abbey there was the
ringing the tolling 96 times of the
kennel Bell yeah to The Abbey and uh
you'll have been to uh English Country
Church funerals very much they do the
same thing they ring the bell they
didn't read it 96 times of course yeah
but the single Bell summoning the
faithful together yeah and the mornings
to prayer and I thought that was
something that was because at the heart
of this was it was a state occasion but
it's also an Anglican funeral and the
Commendation when the Archbishop Academy
I haven't always been his greatest fan
we're going to love you and leave you
thank you very much leeway you're being
replaced for one of the world's greatest
historians I'm sure you won't mind there
he is waging the winds as we sell them
fast enough to see what he thinks about
this from a historical perspective
there he is well tonight Queen Elizabeth
II it's been laid to rest with her
husband Prince Philip at a private
ceremony earlier she arrives Us in
George's chapel and Windsor for an
intimate committal service and one last
public goodbye she was separated from a
crown Auburn scepter for the final time
[Music]
foreign
political sketch writers Quentin Ladson
talked to be contributor Esther Krakow
what a day I mean from a historian point
of view what were you thinking as you
watched all this unfold today magical uh
extraordinary can any other country on
Earth do it like that why are a quarter
of the world's population is it more or
less about that listening to this what
are they thinking what do they think of
these extraordinary buildings and
traditions and is this going to be the
final moment is this the end of the long
second world war and now there will be
just a long recessional for Britain as
it goes forward or can we reinvent
ourselves post-brexit and with a new
monarch and find a new identity and
sense of purpose what's the answer well
I think we absolutely can I think the
model is going to be really important in
that I think we all misunderstand them
on it the Monarch is like the chair of a
company the the Monarch keeps the
tradition the history
values as well absolutely I mean look 15
Prime Ministers for for Elizabeth
birthday come and go they strut on the
stage they signify not very much very
few of them make any difference the
monarchy holds Britain in the uh in in
its arms and carries it forward it cares
about the physical fabric the culture
the Traditions it cares about the Deep
education so I think the monarchy yeah I
mean I think Charles was ahead of his
time in so many ways I what I felt today
was
certainly quite strongly at various
points was after all the chaos of uh
government the Boris Johnson
Administration party Gates all that kind
of stuff reminded of course of the
picture of the queen at Phillips Funeral
on her own in a mask obeying the rules
because she thought that was her Duty
and it turned out half of down the
street were on the Lash inside the
building uh the night before and so on
you know all that sort of disrespect and
undignified conduct in the highest
echelons of our establishment this was a
reminder actually of the very very best
of our conduct as a country and dignity
and establishment
world-class servant leadership we loved
her because she it was never about me
her publicity her money she was
dignified she cared for people she knew
how to behave adults I wonder how those
leaders in the Abbey today and those
watching who wish they were there think
who lead often brutal arrogant uh
selfish that's a very interesting point
wasn't it Quentin by the Archbishop of a
Canterbury when he made the speech about
why the queen was so beloved because she
gave herself to service to others and
she's you know unlike he said those who
cling to power and privilege and you
were looking around the room thinking
well there's quite a few here and he was
pointing straight down the South trance
he was a point which is where all the
world leaders were sitting so uh uh well
done well beyond that front yeah I think
that's just go back to this idea of the
the this this uh event today but also
the last 10 days has been about a
Revival of peacefulness yeah and that
has been why the queen was one of the
reasons was that she was so dearly left
was that she was this idea of Silence
against all the to do and clamor of the
political world now we're in inevitably
going to return to some of that clamor
but maybe it can just be a little bit do
you know what's frantic do you know what
I wish you were right I've got a
horrible feeling
quickly probably tomorrow morning we're
all going to get stuck back into but
even just hearing new peers talking
about partygate there it suddenly felt
terribly old no I'm not talking about
that no no no but I know what you mean
the idea of all that I'm all concerned
about the the actual reality of the cost
of living crisis yes no that would be
much more honorable of the war in Europe
and so on so there's lots of massive
massive things for a rookie prime
minister and a rookie Monarch to have to
go into eternity I want to bring in
Douglas Murray who I think you're in New
York Douglas
I am I do what's it been like to be in
New York watching all this as as a Brit
from afar
well of course it's very painful in many
ways because there's nothing that makes
you feel so homesick of seeing
everything at home uh so incredibly well
and dignifiedly performed seeing the
real depths we have in Britain the
extraordinary Rich traditions we have
it's very painful to see it and not to
be a part of it but I'm sure that many
millions of people around the world have
felt bad
um for me the extraordinary thing about
the day was not just again the
opportunity to reflect on the legacy of
Elizabeth II and indeed to think forward
as so many people have but to reflect on
one of the things that the queen said
several times in her Christmas messages
which was to remind us not to throw out
things just because newfangled ideas
come in and today we saw a number of
British institutions perhaps all of them
at their very best and Britain and
britishness has been undergoing a very
strange business in the last 20 years
forever questioning itself forever
saying what are we who are we and and
really the answer was there today
Britain is a set of Institutions which
reciprocates the public it mirrors the
public the public are the institutions
institutions of the public the
institution gains its legitimacy not by
Force of Arms but by honoring the public
and the public then honor them back the
reciprocity of Institutions was there
today of the House of Commons the house
of laws and of course the Church of
England and that's one of the most
interesting ones of course today because
we saw the proper traditional rights of
the Church of England both of them were
in Westminster Abbey and in St George's
Windsor the Church of England over
recent decades for a long time now has
been throwing out its great liturgy has
been throwing away the great musical
tradition that it has one of the richest
musical traditions in the world but we
saw it again today and we heard it again
today and we saw that this is what is
appropriate to the Deep moments like
this so I would like to think that after
today among many other things we might
reflect on the fact that we have great
inheritances in Britain which it is our
task to sustain because they are things
of Great Value I completely concur with
every single word he just said
beautifully put I want to bring in a
broadcaster and campaigner Dame Esther
Ransom now okay master I I was I knew
you were coming on tonight I was
thrilled to hear you're coming on and as
I've been waiting to speak to you just
being confirmed the queen has now been
buried beside her husband Prince Philip
you of course had famously of a
wonderful marriage and sadly lost your
husband I felt the queen went quite
downhill quite fast after she lost
Philip what did you feel looking at that
from afar
uh
yes possibly
um I obviously that love that
partnership sustained until she said so
didn't she I stay in my rock and those
of us who've had Partners who have been
supportive not uncritical
you know not doormats but certainly
there when you need them it makes a huge
difference and I was very
mindful of the number of people I mean
Desi died in the year 2000 so I've had
22 years to get used to it but I know a
lot of the callers to the Silver Line
you know when people live the great the
price you pay for old age is that you
lose your
closest relatives your closest friends
sometimes and so I was talking to people
on the silver line helpline I think we
should pay tribute to all the people of
in all the Charities who were working
today because they knew that they would
be people that needed them and that was
true both of child Vine and of the
silver line but one of the callers today
said
I'm at home dressed in black I've got
flowers and I've prepared my lunch so
I'm ready to watch the funeral the
Queen's death has brought back memories
of when my sister died it's such a sad
day
you know I think for a lot of people
it wasn't only an opportunity to watch
these magnificent funerals both in the
Abbey and uh in Windsor which was so
moving wasn't it the the smaller funeral
too
but it was also a moment to try perhaps
and come to terms with one's own loss
or maybe if there's someone in our own
lives or in our friendship group that
maybe
having grief stirred up by memories
maybe we should bring them up and say or
um or actually loneliness it was a
wonderfully evocative cartoon and my
time today I don't know if you saw it by
Morton Morland which went viral online
today and just you know the the cartoon
speaks for itself it's uh an elderly man
on his own with an empty chair next to
him clearly uh his partner who we
presume has has died watching the
funeral on his own and it really
resonated with people because that's
really about loneliness one of the many
things of course at Silverline tackles
so well with our elderly in this country
but loneliness can be very difficult for
people particularly at times like this
which are unifying times and people do
like to watch them with their Partners
or wives or husbands or families
whatever it may be if you have no one to
watch it with it can almost exacerbate
the feelings of loneliness and grief
that you may have
I think that's absolutely right peers I
I I totally agree with you I think
when I wrote about my feelings of
loneliness I had the most touching
letter from a gentleman I got to know
well called Bob who died just before his
100th birthday and he said that it was
at that time 65 years since um he
married his beloved Catherine recently
died of Alzheimer's but he said more to
the point 72 years since we first kissed
and she waited for me throughout the war
and I for her loneliness tell me about
it yeah and I think an awful lot of
people of the Queen's generation but not
only of the Queen's generation will be
missing desperately the shoulder that
they used to lean on the hat they used
to hold yes day Master thank you very
much indeed for joining me greatly
appreciate it on this very historic day
for the country
um Anthony Selden
we've got to look now to the new king
the future
um Lord Danny earlier talking about the
need to be positive as a country we've
got a lot of different difficult issues
to deal with how important is this
Monarch going to be in positioning that
positivity for the country do you think
well he's in a slight trap isn't he
because if he does talk out about the
issues he cares about he will get
slaughtered the media and critics uh
have held off attacking the queen she
was simply unassailable and now there's
a lot of pent-up rage and they're just
looking for Charles to make a slip and
yet if he doesn't assert himself as the
long-term voice of the custodian at
monarchy we talk about the welfare
monarchy we need to talk about the
custodian monarchy nobody else can care
for this country and it's long-term
vitality and interest better than the
monarch the Prime Minister they're
elected on lender and majority your
right monarchies are in Decline those
that are left Japan does well very few
no one I don't think does it as well as
Britain underpinning democracy finding
that way forward with Liz trussen with
her successes to somehow get the best
out of the British people make it work
again so we're not looking back we're
looking forward and Britain has a unique
role in the world not just because of
its language and its culture and its
history where there's so much to be
proud of
but after it's a big challenge for these
two rookies yeah definitely the rookie
Monarch albeit incredibly well qualified
and the rookie prime minister who you
know came up two weeks ago I came back
from a break and there was the new prime
minister and then the next day she met
the queen and then two days later the
queen was dead and we have a new King
and then we have this today this is an
extraordinary baptism of fire for a
prime minister already facing Myriad
difficult challenges absolutely and you
know what's funny I I hear that the
Queen's favorite Prime Minister was
actually Churchill right because she was
in all of him it was the first Prime
Minister exactly I think probably in
terms of character the most that she was
responsible yes because he he epitomized
resilience and determination and
stoicism and his thing was keep
buggering on kbo hers would just get on
with it you know similar kind of
attitude yeah and I'm I'm really hoping
that list trust has that same attitude
because we know that she's facing a
myriad of problems I actually really do
not envy her because I wouldn't want to
be in a position but I also you know I
actually feel for Charles as well
because this is his kind of his first
role of the dice in that way and he's
really stepping into this huge role the
the future of the monarchy effectively
rests on his shoulders it's not it's not
an easy thing exactly we've got a few
minutes left uh quenching sum up this
day and and what it means and how
history will judge this day do you think
well this day will that I think be
bigger than the effect that will have a
bigger effect than the funeral of poor
Diana did Arthur Diana's death the
country changed I think we can all
remember that in the country became
better at gushing and being more
emotional and more relaxed about life
and I suspect there may be a little bit
of a tilt of the other Wing now after
this because I think I suspect that what
Douglas was saying is correct and that
in our wider culture and in our poets
and our writers and our painters and our
musicians will perhaps reconnect with
the idea that the old and the
traditional had some value yes and so I
think there may be some of that I I
wouldn't go you were talking earlier
about but um you know the tremendous
challenges facing the prime minister in
the king I think you're alluding too
much onto those two people and uh
they're the figureheads right events
take their course electoral politics
will happen yeah whatever happens and uh
that will probably go wrong for somebody
that's always happens well case Garner's
gonna play the Nationals
we haven't heard that for a while the
king himself the the the the the the I
think the ideal for me would be a king
who is just there who is alongside us
who is a sympathetic ear who is not
trying to look after our morale let's
look after our own morale Douglas um
have we got to stop apologizing as a
country for our past would that be a
good way to move positively forward
a good way to move forward isn't just to
stop apologizing but to actually know
about it uh there was a time maybe a
couple hundred years ago where anyone
saying anything negative about Britain
might have had a bit of a problem
domestically today it's the exact
reverse of that the inverse of it unless
you bash Britain uh people thinking
you're doing something wrong uh look at
all the people who've come out of the
woodwork in the last couple of weeks
with the rancid opinions about our
history and our culture I I would say
that the the the job of us now is to
retain and explain that's something
people use in museum terminology we
retain our culture and we explain it to
people many people around the world will
have watched today's events and been
wondering what's that about who's that
what's the symbolism of that but they'll
have learned some of it and you know we
have seen an extraordinary period And as
anti-seldom as I have just just
mentioned we've seen a transition of a
monarch and a prime minister within days
of each other and what other country in
the world would be able to carry out a
peaceful transition like that but our
own country other countries including
America can't manage it imagine if we'd
been undergoing a presidential election
and a prime ministerial election the
point is that Britain continues the
monarchy continues our institutions
continue but they don't continue nearly
Like Oxygen they continued because the
people who are committed to them sustain
them and so I would like to think that
people remember after a day like today
that the job of any generation isn't
just to sustain what is good but to keep
it going to pass it on and that is
something that I think many people will
have been inspired to do from today and
to remember as Quentin just said that we
had other values that aren't so bad it's
not so good to let everything out it's
not so good to be me me me me time it's
good to live a life of service to your
nation to to your circle around you to
your loved ones and to the things that
matter yeah and if we ever saw somebody
who epitomized that it was Elizabeth II
absolutely right Douglas Murray thank
you very much indeed for joining me it's
Randy Selden thank you Quentin let's
Esther cracker well that brings an end
to our to our special we could have done
probably 22 hours frankly on what
happened today it was just a unique
extraordinary wondrous day in so many
ways this country and its absolute
greatest the greatest for pomp for
pageantry for monarchy but also the
greatest for the values that this
Monarch represented and I've talked
about this a few times in last 10 days I
want to end by reminding people what
those values are so that we can all try
and learn and take from those values
stoicism resilience dignity humility
strength of character not playing the
victim don't complain all the time don't
explain too much
be careful what you say and when you say
it mean it and stand by your own
principles don't get blown in the Wind
by whatever the next headline is if
you're like that you will be more like
our Queen and that will make us all
better people so thank you your majesty
again for everything that you taught us
and that leads us to our final farewell
to Britain's greatest ever modern
it's goodbye to Queen Elizabeth II and
our heartfelt gratitude
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we come to this house of God where Queen
Elizabeth was married and crowned We
Gather from Across the Nation from the
Commonwealth and from the nations of the
world to mourn our loss
he that hath seen me hath seen the
father
thanks be to God
all who follow the Queen's example and
inspiration of trust and faith in God
can with her say
we will
meet again
[Music]